the irony is as delicious as a spicy
chicken sandwich with extra pickles and
grilled jalapenos
the same people who accused liberals of
being intolerant cancel culture
supporting lunatics
are now themselves calling for a boycott
of Chick-fil-A
because Chick-fil-A is now being
inclusive and respectful the same people
who previously defended Chick-fil-A's
right to express its religious beliefs
which happen to be Christian those
people are now outraged that Chick-fil-A
is trying to live up to its mission of
glorifying God by being a good Steward
by having this Dei inclusivity statement
and it seems to me that some of these
conservatives must think that to be
faithful to God you shouldn't be
inclusive and want equity and want
diversity seems to me that that is quite
Godly isn't it